hi I'm Jen and I'm Nikki and today we're
talking about the untold stories of
queer people throughout history whoo
we're gonna look into some rulers and
stories that are already there
they're already floating around outing
is still not okay folks but these people
are long dead and we are doing nobody's
life any harm by talking about them in
fact we're probably making your life
better Hey yes we're talking about the
highly sought-after very very popular
founding father Alexander Hamilton Oh
Alexander Hamming ham ham as popularized
by lin-manuel Miranda and his play Brent
Alexander Hamilton rumored to have had
intimate relationships as men outside of
his marriage to Eliza Schuyler
interesting question was he president
what do you know about him other than he
was not president I honestly don't know
enough so hit me Alexander Hamilton was
born January 11th 1757 in the British
West Indies to a father who abandoned
him and a mother who died when he was 11
okay
not a great start but he was very smart
so his friends and family were like wow
this kids really smart we got it I could
do something about it so they sent him
to a prep school in New Jersey and then
later he gets to go to King's College in
New York which is actually now Columbia
I mean link and then BAM it's pretty
much the revolutionary around this time
he marries Elizabeth Schuyler Oh
beautiful socialite who's hot she's cute
and she's written oh she's just like me
yeah and rich while he's in school in
New York revolts against Great Britain
start and he becomes an influential
voice in speaking out for the rebellion
cut to february 1777 George Washington
invites Alexander Hamilton to be his
aide-de-camp which is like a secretary
administrative role in the military and
then guess who else is also an aide to
camp around this time John Lauren
Starnes born in 1754 has a very
different upbringing than Hamilton
grows up rich gets sent to a fancy prep
school in Switzerland but like how
romantic you know like he's got
everything growing up Hamilton's got
nothing growing up it's like the
beginning of a movie some people believe
that Hamilton
Loren's shared more than a close
friendship another biographer named Ron
yeah Ron he says at the very least we
can say that Hamilton developed
something like an adolescent crush on
his friend John Lawrence at the very
least we're going more than get the very
least a little further we're going to
the most also it's fishy because
Hamilton's son who is responsible for
his father's biography purposefully
leaves things out about Hamilton and
Lawrence to me it sort of speaks to
trying to preserve this image of his
father yeah the basis of these rumors is
in the letters that Hamilton and Lorenz
exchange we need to note that this is
wartime emotions are high yeah here we
go
cold in my professionals warm in my
friendships I wish my dear Lawrence it
might be in my power by action rather
than words to convince you that I love
you I shall only tell you that till you
obeyed us a Jew I hardly knew the value
you had taught my heart to set upon you
don't make eye contact with me I mean
it's gonna head of it because he talks a
lot but he goes on to say you should not
have taken advantage of my sensibility
to steal into my affections without my
consent but as you have done it and as
we are generally indulgent to those we
love
I shall not scruple to pardon a fraud
you have committed on condition that
from my sake if not for your own you
will always continue to merit the
partiality which you have so artfully
instilled into me ha but immediately you
feel Jonnie and uncomfortable yeah I'm I
am trying to squeeze it up into myself
that is somebody who is in love this is
my translation okay hey dude I wish I
could show you how much I love you not
just write you letters look at how you
made me like you so much I'll forgive
you for seducing me because I kind of
like it a lot this letter is pretty odd
on multiple accounts because later
Hamilton then asks Lawrence to help him
find a wife while he's in South Carolina
Oh to excite there there being the
honey's emulation it will be necessary
for you Lawrence to give an account of
the lover his size make quality of mind
and body
achievements expectations fortune at
try in drawing my picture you will no
doubt be civil to your friend mind you
do justice to the length of my nose and
don't forget that I the letter is
scratched out after that some people him
believe that he was talking about his
dinghy because literally he's like oh
you have to like go talk me up to the
ladies and find me a wife don't forget
to tell them about my body and the
length of my nose the fact that there is
like some sexual undertones makes me
think that there was at least a [ __ ]
and in other letters to Lawrence
Hamilton refers to himself and his
actions as those of a jealous lover I
have still a part for the public and
another for you so if your impatience to
have me married as misplaced a strange
cure by the way as if after matrimony I
was to be less devoted than I am now let
me tell you that I intend to restore the
Empire of hymen and that Cupid is to be
his prime minister I wish you are at
liberty to transgress the bounds of
Pennsylvania I would invite you after
the fall to Albany to witness the final
constant
they were [ __ ] seriously that to me
this letter is to me the clearest sign
cuz Hamilton is basically saying you
want me to get married because you think
we're gonna stop being in love once I'm
married but you're wrong as hell not
language you used to someone you were
speaking to strictly platonic ly so we
have a lot of letters from Hamilton
fewer from Lauren's but the ones we do
have access to he writes to Hamilton
shortly before he dies oh do you wanna
read those you can be ones I do my dear
friend
well circumstances place so great a
distance between us I entreat you not to
withdraw the consolation of your letters
you know the unalterable sentiments of
your affectionate Lawrence less flowery
language but still clear and intention
don't stop sexting me cuz I kind of like
it down Lawrence unfortunately guys he
was one of the last casualties of the
Revolutionary War so back to the
biographers he also says that after
Lawrence died Hamilton never found a
close friend like him again
there's just like a part of him that
died with that was never the same
yeah what happens to Alexander so the
Revolutionary War ends
Hamilton helps draft up what Congress is
gonna look like studies law helps right
most of the Federalist Papers Hamilton
dies in a duel with Aaron Burr
just to clarify duel is when you turn
around you both shoot each other yes it
was a difficult time you know people
just really fascinates with duels and
words I mean interesting and fascinating
that there was perhaps a young love
between these two men I mean it sounds
like a great movie you know so I hope
you guys had fun and learned a little
bit of something today about our
founding father Alexander Hamilton we'll
never know for sure but at the very
least we can speculate and wildly assert
that they were for sure in love married
and will never forget each other yeah if
there's someone that you suspect is
queer throughout history let us know
maybe we'll talk about it bye everybody
see you next time
[Music]